hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control SI dot
l2-3.14.3 monitor system security alerts
and advisories and take action in
response
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp80171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance hero
let's jump into it in this control we
get the express directive the Mandate
that we must do what we already know
we're supposed to be doing which in my
opinion yes this control is absolutely
needed I mean I think again everybody
needs a reminder especially when it's
something really important so what this
is all about
having reviewed hundreds of
organizations and worked with thousands
of I.T people over the years there's a
fairly Universal pattern that exists I
almost don't want to say it on camera
but it really is that common the IT
people are given a security directive
they research and buy the solution and
just as they get it set up and installed
are pulled on to the next pants on fire
emergency and never really customize or
fully set up that security solution with
the vendor support the way it's supposed
to be and then a lot of times it's not
even really reporting into their their
ticketing systems or their email at all
as a result the solution is never really
being monitored it's actually being set
up to go to the right excuse me it's not
actually being set up uh to its optimal
protection State and worse many times
alerts are never actually being set up
to go to the right place yuck but it
happens all the time and if you are one
of those overwhelmed I.T directors out
there in this situation we feel your
pain like I'm sending you my love but
the pain is going to be a lot bigger if
you don't go back and take whatever time
is needed to get all this properly set
up so look
I know there's no one looking over your
shoulder that's like you and me's little
secret so take a minute
all right I don't know tell them you
need an in-service day or something take
a day off but go get your Security
Solutions set up correctly so that
you're really monitoring what's going on
and you're actually getting relevant
alerts because if you don't do that I
promise something silly is going to you
know basically go right between the
cracks and it's going to be a bad bad
day in the office okay you won't be
worrying about time off at that point
you'll just be worrying about where your
next job is going to be I don't want
that to happen to you I just want you
and your company to stay safe so look
let's dive into specifics of how this
should be done all right and take my
warning because believe me it's it's
with such frequency it's terrible
all right three assessment points on
this one determine if response actions
to system uh security alerts and
advisories are identified uh so again if
we were to give a sample answer we would
say it's identified via the IT service
ticket system and incident response plan
so we got a written policy it tells us
how it should be handled and a technical
system that does the work uh and of
course it's reviewed based on risk
management sop another policy that's
going to basically say hey to manage
risk properly we got to do this
now next assessment Point determine if
system security alerts and advisories
are monitored uh implemented via daily
iot operations management by the CIO
again just an example here can be the
CEO it could be all kinds of different
people in this case we'll see the CIO
which includes daily ongoing monitoring
of information security operations
including security alert and advisory
monitoring and response
third assessment Point determine if
actions in response to system security
alerts and advisories are taken so in
other words do you actually take an
action when you get the alert
it sounds like really big Common Sense
until you find out that there's broken
pieces of the chain
so if we were to give a sample answer on
this one it would be implemented the IIT
service ticket system and incident
response plan reviewed based on risk
management standard operating procedures
okay all of those are essential elements
to get you passed so hey an on-call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this D fars nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped into
their laps like Oswego on a sunny day
baby and we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking to get help getting getting more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc complianceecrets.com where we give
away all the secrets to getting
compliant and getting ready for cmmc
certification or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content I'm putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better
oh smash that subscribe button baby do
it right now right now you've been
delaying it for like the last four
videos hit the Subscribe button because
we make lots of awesome jokes and we
have a lot of fun here and I guarantee
you're never gonna have as much fun
dealing with compliance as you are with
us until the next Appliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]